I lose my ability to think straight or
intelligently in confrontational or
unfriendly social situations any
suggestions for adaptation or
improvement well a couple I suppose one
is is that when you get nervous in this
kind of situation that you're describing
what often happens to people is they
start paying attention to themselves
they get self-conscious so you know
let's say I got self-conscious all of a
sudden during this QA what would happen
is that I'd start paying attention to
the questions and the screen and what
I'm doing and I'd start paying attention
to how I was feeling and to the
nervousness and then I'd start to get
aware that I was not responding properly
and that would make me more nervous and
then I would get more aware of that and
that can just shut me down entirely and
that's happened to me now and then in a
lecture and sometimes almost happened
when I was talking to Sam Harris the
first time I paused for a long time and
then became aware of the pause and then
anyways what you have to do in a
situation like that is it's not so much
that you have to stop attending to
yourself because if you start thinking I
should stop attending to myself then
you'll just think about yourself more
what you have to do instead is pay more
attention to the situation and to the
people that you're talking to so you
have to increase the degree to which
you're attending outwardly and that'll
stop you from attending inwardly that's
a very effective technique you can
practice that generally speaking every
time you get nervous start paying more
attention and that'll that'll that'll
help you out a lot yeah that's really
good suggestion for social anxiety in
general is that if you see most people
but not everyone but most people have
enough implicit social skill because
they were reasonably socialized when
they were children so that they do know
how to act in social situations but they
get anxious and then that interferes
with them implementing
what they know just like if you're a
pianist and you get anxious and
self-conscious while you're playing
you'll forget what you know because
while you've activated a different part
of your brain if you can remember to pay
attention and you can direct your
attention outward and you attend hard
enough then what will happen and try to
put the other person at ease and try to
ask them questions then that'll kick in
the automatic because you're paying
attention to what the person is doing
into their facial expressions and all of
that that will clue in the automatic and
implicit knowledge that you have and
make things much more smooth and and and
anxiety free so attention really
attention really plays a huge role in
regulating anxiety